we
going
live
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to yo
absolutely
[Music]
welcome back to riffin with griffin here
we are once again
[Music]
today we're talking about
choco taco is gone can't even believe it
i uh i have a feeling about french fries
at a steakhouse
that deshawn watson
punishment suspension how i feel about
it
what the internet is saying about it
and i saw this show reacher on amazon
prime but welcome back
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome to riffing with
griffin and we are live in full effect
that's how we do it live
live live i always forget to do this
dude put my little main titles on guys
thank you for watching whiffen with
griffin starring eric griffin
live in aaron griffin studios
at the eric griffin green screen
uh make sure you guys subscribe
share
hit the notifications that's super
important
and you know i also am on twitch
daily error griffin gaming so check me
out there if you just want to support
the show and be a part of the magic uh
you know you could you could be a
patreon member you could be a youtube
member or you could be a subscriber on
twitch you could be a super chat uh twit
super follower on tw twitter any which
way you want to like
help to show monetarily with your
support i whatever you do i appreciate
that stuff greatly um but obviously the
show was brought to you by door dash
doordash love doordash but wish you
didn't have to pay delivery fees well
your dreams will come true during summer
of dash pass that's 50
off your first order up to 15 value with
code griffin terms apply doordash
all right guys welcome to the show
welcome to the show chat um let me put
up a poll
right now
um of what we're you know i guess i'll
put up a couple polls but
first poll i want to put up is um
let's see french fries at a steakhouse
uh
for sure
save that for
mcdonald's that's the poll
all right
uh that's just something i want to talk
about then we'll get into some other
things but yeah so anyways welcome back
to the show guys i had a great week uh
last night uh my
my return to kill tony so make sure you
check that out on youtube had a fun time
with that
uh kill tony was was um that was fun
[Laughter]
um you know what i mean so make sure you
guys uh check that out uh that's on
youtube
um yeah it was just fun going to austin
and like uh the the atmosphere was just
really electric and then i was watching
it live as he was i was watching the
premiere of it live and i was in the
chat and there's so many haters like
it's funny like it's like so it's fun to
be in there to see all that interaction
you know it's like i can't win if i
interact people are like well you're
interested you know why aren't you
looking at your video you're too busy in
the chat and it's like you can't win
with anybody but you know it doesn't
matter had a good time with it and so
make sure you guys check that out after
this uh kill tony was a very fun shout
out to my buddy tony hitchcliff for like
keeping that show going and like
actually raising the level of it in
austin it just was crazy
um i got some shows coming up you will
you could see me in la jolla in san
diego at the comedy store september 9th
to the 11th so make sure you check that
out if you're in la and you're listening
to this right now and you want to see a
show tonight i'm going to be at burbank
flappers i do eric and friends once a
month at flappers last night we did at
the improv great turnout so tomorrow
tonight if you know in burbank if you're
in the burbank area you want to come
check out some you know some shows i do
eric and friends tonight and burbank and
flappers so make sure you guys check
that out
so
um went to this well first of all shout
out to my beautiful wife rachel
rachel
rachel griffin shout out to her
so
we visited steakhouse man really nice
steakhouse in brentwood
and i just i don't know how everybody
else feels about it but i have a i have
i got a problem with french fries at a
steakhouse
i don't i don't care what they do to
them
i don't care how fancy you want to make
them if you want to put truffle butter
on it and then you know
they always have some kind of like
ridiculous fancy thing they're gonna do
with it like oh this mushroom such and
such with the and the french fries with
the parmesan and whatever it's still
french fries
to me when you add a steak house no more
get them out of there get the french
fries out of the steakhouse buy
it's the same reason why you don't get a
baked potato at mcdonald's
you don't go to yeah let me get the the
big mac with the orange soda and the
baked potato
with all the trimmings no because baked
potato is fancy potato
french fries is
that's riff raff that's for like you
know that's fast food i want if you're
gonna make a potato i want you to do it
fancy
even though
is it all really that fancy just to bake
a potato but it's just something about
it it feels more adult
be an adult and get a baked potato stop
getting french fries at a steak house i
hate to see people with uh a 70 steak
and some french fries sitting next to it
i just have a problem with that maybe
i'm too bougie you know and all these
places it had and then all these fast
food places stop making baked potatoes
you not just saying baked potato spot
okay
get some get your french fries different
cuts get your curly fries get the uh
what is it the sweet potato fries all
the different kind of fries that should
be at the at the fast food places uh and
then like you know somebody's asking
about fried wedges i don't know i think
wedges is cheating but that's when you
go in like a breakfast spot i'm just
saying you had a steak house where
it's like market price on the menu where
it's like
the steaks are 50
plus steaks
different trimmings you know all kinds
of tomahawks and and all this kind of
stuff you do not pair that with french
fries
like a animal
that's all i have to say
about
that
you hear me
okay
um so that's the poll up right now i'ma
keep this pole up for a little bit
longer i want to hear what you guys said
and i am just outraged that this pole is
at 62 for sure you peasants
i what's wrong with you people you do
not go get french fries at a steak house
stop it
anyways y'all
what is going on
in the world today um
i just got i think we got some sad news
just found out that choco taco is no
more
look at this choco taco you go to their
website and they have this announcement
the klondike choco taco has
unfortunately been discontinued
over the past two years we have
experienced an unprecedented spike in
demand across our portfolio and have had
to make very tough decisions to ensure
availability of our full portfolio
nationwide
a necessary but unfortunate part of the
process is that we sometimes must
discontinue products even the beloved
item like choco taco
what
how crazy i don't know if you guys have
ever like all you workaholics fans and
thank you jonathan marks for becoming a
uh next level egghead that's what you
are when you become a member on youtube
you become an egghead thank you very
much
original content coming your way
um i don't know if you guys ever saw
if you watched workaholics day we had
like
we had like a uh
um what do you call it like it was
called the other cubicle and it was just
me wayman and jet set and we were doing
like and bill and we were doing funny
you know little like
like side pieces to workaholics and it
was sponsored by choco taco the boys
just one day
started like just randomly on the show
just started uh they just made a a choco
taco joke
and the next thing you know
the the company heard about it and then
they just they they sponsored the show
so we were doing like it was almost like
we were doing a commercial for choco
taco so it's just you know i don't know
why they get rid of stuff like this but
i mean choco taco is a mess though i
mean
talk about cultural appropriation
it was just like a ice cream cone
shape it was an ice cream cone shaped
like a taco and then you know
you it had like chocolate peanuts and an
ice cream in it i don't know brilliant
idea
uh i just
i i know i don't know if i was a huge
choco taco fan i mean my favorite ice
cream dessert is an ice cream sandwich
and a plain ice cream sandwich okay
plain vanilla ice cream sandwich i
couldn't stand the one that was like
chocolate vanilla and strawberry pick a
flavor [__] you know what i mean what
what what we doing
just
just have a all strawberry one
have a all chocolate one or have a all
vanilla one but those that's my favorite
ice cream dessert
uh is all is an ice cream sandwich so
choco taco is like similar to that
because you're still getting like it's
just like an ice cream that you could
hold differently i guess a taco is a
better way to hold you know i don't know
what what you guys would get i don't
know if i actually like ice cream cones
that are like that
like the you know that sort of cone
i kind of like the other regular type of
ice cream cone if i get ice cream but i
haven't even had ice cream in a while
it's so fatty sometimes i get like if i
go to in and out with rachel
she likes in and out every like two
months so we'll go to in and out and
sometimes i'll be in the in-n-out line
and i'll be like let me get a strawberry
shake that's my weakness i get a
strawberry shake but like ice cream
like ice cream is so good
like i don't i don't
eat a lot of ice cream anymore i don't
have it in the fridge it's just rare
i'll have a shake every now and then
right but ice cream like i don't have
yogurt at all
i don't know if you guys are yogurt
people are you yogurt people okay
uh
i just every time i have like frozen
yogurt
i'm just kind of like this ain't ice
cream because that's all it's trying to
be like it's supposed to be like a more
healthier ice cream but i just want ice
cream when you have frozen
if you have frozen yogurt and you've
been eating it all the time you're like
oh frozen yogurt is my jam
when you have some ice cream
you go oh
this is what this frozen yogurt is
supposed to taste like so i don't want i
don't like doing that to myself i don't
care what it is like they always have
these dumb flavors you ever go to the
yogurt place and you get the little
sample and it'll say like strawberry
[__] don't taste like strawberry at all
you know oh boysenberry blackberry
whatever berry lemon lime all these
different flavors um you know peanut
butter the actually the peanut butter is
the only one that sort of tastes like
peanut butter i don't know where you
guys stand on that but like
all these flavors that all taste like
versions of yogurt okay
and then you have some ice cream
and you're like
oh
yeah this is what this yogurt is it's
like a vegan burger man when you have
vegan meat and then you have some real
meat you like get this [__] out of
my face why am i eating this vegan meat
you know it's like i don't care you know
it's like just stop pretending stop
acting like this this is the same thing
it's not
ice cream is way better than yogurt okay
new poll
[Laughter]
when you watch live you get to be a part
of the polls
let's see what's better
yogurt
ice cream
this should be a landslide
hit me with it
you know i just i don't know i just when
i see that it just drives me bananas
so anyways all right peter choco taco i
feel like it's gonna come back i feel
like this is how you build up demand so
it's like so yeah let's get you know i
don't know if we start a petition who we
tweet at if we tweet that klondike i
have no idea but
why can't they just make the ch what
like how maybe the choco taco takes too
much
production is too much production you
know because you got to have the thing
you got to fold it you got to get the
ice cream in it you got to put the
chocolate in the peanuts you got to
package it a certain way maybe it's just
easier to make the other klondi bars and
all that kind of stuff i didn't even
know choco taco was a klondike uh
company so you know shout out you know
if you guys go to their website klondike
or just google choco taco apparently
it's just it's just gun it's just done
you know what i mean so
is what it is
um
i don't know
like i say it is what it is all right
let's get into the real stuff man
um i'm not sure what kind of episode's
gonna be today or how long we're gonna
be but
you know it is what it is
so
as you guys i don't know if you guys
have heard
or if you're like not into football or
whatever it is if you're not into
football um
if you've heard this or not but
you know as you know uh the cleveland
browns
uh new quarterback is desean watson
um deshawn watson and he
desean watson has uh you know it came
out
that he likes to get massages and he
gets massages from numerous different
massage therapists
and
24 women
um
accused him of misconduct let me say it
again in case you didn't know about this
24 different massage therapists
uh made claims against deshaun watson of
inappropriate behavior a a new york
times article i believe it was new york
times but it was some paper out of new
york
did their own investigating and came to
find out that he has had
66 different massage therapists in a two
three year span
and
he um
you know
and so like i said and then 24 of them
he has since settled i believe 20 of the
cases
um
he still proclaims his innocence
and
in this process he was on the what do
you call it the commissioner's exempt
list last year and he did not play all
of last year
before that though he was in houston
and he was demanding a trade he said he
would never play for houston again
and then this all this came out which
which which messed up his leverage
really because you know this is like a
damning thing and it's terrible all
these allegations
and he um you know he but he didn't play
so he he was he did not play all last
year and so
as this investigating has been going on
a few things have happened
first thing first thing that happened is
he was there was an investigation
i believe a grand jury was called
and they found no criminal activity
where they couldn't prove any criminal
activity so there was they because there
was a grand jury uh you know wherever it
was and they came out and said there
will be no
criminal
charges
against him
so finding out that there's going to be
no criminal charges against him
that triggered then the nfl to be like
we are back in the deshaun watts in
business
uh so then some teams were vying for his
services
and the cleveland browns gave him the
largest contract in guaranteed contract
in nfl history
something like 230 250 million dollars
guaranteed
and by the way the first year of his
contract
he's only making a million dollars
something like 60 000 a game and that
was them anticipating him being
suspended i'll get back to that
so that triggered that so they signed
him
then the nfl took
some time to figure out what is his
punishment going to be if they were
going to do a punishment i think they
were waiting on if they're going to be
criminal charges there was no criminal
charges now it's about what they feel
the embarrassment of the game you've
embarrassed the integrity of the game
and they have an outside arbitrator now
instead of the commissioner making all
these decisions they have this outside
arbitrator saying uh you know we're
going to have this person decide and
it's actually a judge a female judge by
the way if that matters or not and she
just came out with a ruling that he
should get six-game
suspension that's where we are right now
um you know that's where we are so i um
um you know and i will i will put a poll
up
was six games
enough
of a
suspension okay yes no okay
all right and you know i mean i'm sure
if you want to say something in the chat
you most certainly can
so
where do i stand on this
okay
so
i don't know if you guys get massages i
get massages regularly and i go to the
same place every time the same person
because you know once you get a good
massage you're like
they know you they you you feel like
they get to know your body you feel
comfortable and it's just like it
actually is very hard to find a good
massage therapist so all right
i'm just going to be 100 and real about
this whole thing i'm doing this live so
i'm trying to be very sensitive and cost
and cautious about not just being like
like just saying some wild crazy [__]
because that's not what i'm about
all right the first thing is this um
what do you call it um deshaun watson
obviously has an issue okay whether he
he proclaims his innocence that he
didn't do anything wrong all right even
though all these women have very similar
stories 66 all together 24 are said he
did something inappropriate or they felt
uncomfortable whatever it is the
arbitrator that came out with the ruling
for six games said there was there was
nothing criminal about what happened but
that doesn't mean that anything that
doesn't mean that something wrong didn't
happen so obviously i'm saying this do
you like getting massages and did you
like obviously getting uh
you know some extra services done okay
um
you know you you would think
you know
he got enough money to like have a
masseuse that maybe he has an
arrangement with but i don't think
that's what it was about people often
think that in no situation that's what
it's about it's about like that you know
instant gratification there but i think
a part of what he gets off on is
going to a strange massage therapist and
some stuff happening okay that's his
thing that's his kink that's his fetish
he don't want to come out with it and be
like hey this is true that this is like
this is who i am because that's maybe
more damning to him i don't know maybe
he should
um i'm sure that there are some places
you go that some massage therapists you
go to that are totally down with this i
think you know that's why it's not 66 uh
you know
lawsuits and that there are some also
some women who are afraid to come out
and don't want to say anything because
of the backlash that happens when women
come out with these types of things and
we have to acknowledge that that happens
and it does okay so that is a true that
is a true thing that is unfortunately in
our society okay so just on the desean
watson part he got a he has a it's a
thing whether you think he did something
criminal or not it was stupid
all right you're you're a high-profile
nfl player
and you're doing this
this kind of stuff comes out you know we
all make mistakes i think he made a huge
mistake
whether he did anything whether he did
something criminal or not that's not for
me to say but obviously a lot of women
were made to feel uncomfortable uh that
they were in a situation they didn't
want to be in and so here we are so what
do we do what do we do about this
what what would you want to happen if it
were you for me what do i do i control
the nfl how do i handle this situation
you know i think if it were me how do i
handle this situation it's like i i go
to this guy and i go what the hell why
you know
you've won you've embarrassed us
two the optics look terrible okay
whether you think he's innocent or not
he has brought this uncomfortable thing
to the nfl and now we got women who are
already feeling
already feel like they can't get justice
feeling like oh man what is this so if
it were me i think the nfl should have
came strong it's it's not saying they
think he's guilty or innocent or
whatever but just a stupid tax he should
have paid i think he should have been
suspended for a year last year with you
know suspended
with a fine or without pay okay i think
that's what they should have done last
year they should have jumped right on it
and maybe two years i mean there's a guy
in the in an mlb that had some situation
they suspended him for two years i mean
jason watson was already willing not to
play because he didn't want to play for
houston so i mean just get on top of it
i think just for even for the sake of
nfl they had to do their investigating
but once all this came out it's just the
optics of it like listen
we're not a court of law and in the
court of public opinion is different
from the court of law the court of
public opinion goes to the bottom line
if the bottom line is affected then it's
a whole different conversation and
they're just going to get rid of the guy
right the bottom line hasn't we don't
know how the bottom line is going to be
affected
and this has put the nfl in a super
uncomfortable situation because there
are a lot of female fans out there and
i'm sure that the female fans out there
feel like wow
really six games and that's it
and like i said earlier on top of that
his contract is
put together in such a way
that the first year of his contract he's
only making 60 000 a game
as if they anticipated that he was going
to be suspended so you're saying that
this six game fine is you know
six six times 60 is what is that uh
whatever the math is on that
uh so what's what is he going to lose
240 250 000 and that's it
so
on top of that
to me
it looks bad
you know like regardless of they're not
a court they're not putting down
judgment on whether he is guilty or
innocent but you can come down and be
like yo this looks terrible for our
company and our female fans
and
they i think they should have made a
stronger choice
you know
you know what i mean and that's just how
i feel about it
you know you you look at
you look at especially with the like
like like what's the real punishment
here
so what is the punishment
is it the games because he didn't even
play all last year
so is not playing the punishment for him
or is it loss of money is that the
punishment
to me i feel like they should have fined
him a million dollars a game for last
year
so 17 million dollar fine
and time served you take that 17 million
million dollars from him
since there's gonna be no criminal case
you take the 17 million dollars and you
either give it to the victims or you sub
you know or you support
these type of causes uh women's right
whatever it is uh abuse of you know
shelters what however you want to do it
but you take that 17 million dollars and
you do some good will with it okay and
then he has now been punished monetarily
and he already missed 17 games and we
move on with our lives and these
hopefully these women can move on with
their lives but you have to make a
statement to me that you care about the
abuse
that you care about the position that
these women are in
it's like
i i you know you know what i mean
because here's the thing too let's also
be 100 about the actual stance of the
nfl
the dude's still going to play he was
still allowed to sign a 230 50 million
dollar contract and he's eventually
going to play business as usual so as
much as they want to say hey
we are worried about how this looks and
what people think about our league and
what people think about
of the abuse of women
you know they ultimately are like okay
we're going to deal with that as much as
we can but what we really care about is
getting this
high high talent very highly talented
football player back on the field
how you feel about that is
what you have to ask yourself honestly
you have to ask yourself honestly how do
you feel about what the nfl
feels about that
now you could go back and forth there's
a lot of people that that feel like oh
man they think what all these women are
lying
here's my thing even if you think all
these women are lying what i'm saying is
it ain't a good look
the optics of it are terrible you know
and so
and just one and then it's you know one
woman with all the same stories coming
out and being like yo this is what
happened to me and then you see them
talking in their news things it's kind
of like you gotta punish him even just
to be like bro
like this is why would you do it this
way there's instagram messages and we've
all like i said we've all made mistakes
okay
let's see if at the softest end of this
is that you know
you know this just was a perverted thing
he had this perversion that he's out
there doing
and it's like to me it's like as long as
you're not hurting anybody you know do
what you got to do okay
but if like if you believe that he was
being super aggressive and intimidating
and these women had no choice and you
feel like they were like put in a
situation where they were like well i
guess i gotta i gotta do this for this
guy or is he gonna get violent like you
know what if if that is that that is the
case and they were if they felt that way
all right it's like yo bro you have to
own that
like i can believe that desean watson
did not have
malice intent
when it came to like you know like was
he in there being like you know you you
know grabbing their arms or something or
like really looking them like if you
don't do this it's gonna be pro and i
don't know if that's how we did it but
he could have been very like you know
hey come on come on you know i'll pay
you money or whatever he was doing it
was perverted it was a perversion that
got out into the public's eye
i don't know if you guys remember when
um
what's his name the basketball announcer
you know it came out that he was he like
wearing women's clothes
in um
in the bedroom you know
and that came out and it was like a
thing and they uh what was the guy's
name
why am i another guy yes
um man i'm getting old man
losing my memory but um if you i'm sure
you guys remember the guy's name in the
in the chat uh
you know
you know whatever whatever
you know you know
and so they said they ended up
suspending him and it's marv albert
thank you very much marv albert
so marv albert's situation you know it's
like you know having a perversion
having a thing
you know you you know but when it gets
out in the public and you're like a
public figure then you have to deal with
it right
i don't know all the details of the
desean watson situation i didn't read
the details of the case i didn't read
like what these women had ultimately
said about him i don't know if there was
like some something in there where they
felt super intimidated by his presence
again
even if that wasn't his intention he has
to see like if 24 people are saying this
about you and then you look at your
record of like 66 times you know you've
had different massage therapists it's
got to be like okay i messed up you know
what i mean i messed up and the nfl is
basically coming out and being like yo
you know dude
we don't need this out we're we're
trying to be a family business right
we're trying to be a a violent
family business that you know
gives people cte whatever your p or
whatever your opinion is on that so you
know it's a billion dollar business and
this guy
sullied this billion dollar business so
that's one side of it just monetarily
and all that how it affects them they
have a vested interest to like come down
on him and be like hey man we got to do
this
you know we got to do this whether you
feel like you're innocent or not all
right uh and then it's like
just the optics of it just don't look
good man and when you go to twitter and
i just you know i put into sean watson's
name and i went into twitter and you
could just see how a lot of people are
feeling about this
you know like this is desean watson
situation is a slap in the face to every
female nfl fan you know and that's like
that's a sentiment that you see a lot of
uh lots of talk about privilege on
social media athletic privileges the
apex how many people could be publicly
accused of sexual assault by 30 women
and not keep their current job
you know that's a part of it too you
know you're talking about
you know rich people rich privilege man
you know rich privilege is a real thing
um
you know what i mean like somebody said
so they basically the nfl banned deshaun
watson one quarter for every sexual
accusation that's the the the look of it
right now you know what i'm saying
so it's like whatever you feel about him
or not
this is you know
this is
um
[Music]
this is a serious
situation you know
um
because like even if like you know i
mean dude there's websites for this you
know
like there's like like i believe there's
like rub and tug type
places like um there's places you can go
that like this is just an acceptable
thing and you're paying money out of
pocket so
again this is just a stupid thing
where it's like hey if that's your thing
that's what you're into you can find
places that you're into but he seemed to
really get off on
like like you know like a a strange like
legit massage therapist also doing that
for him
uh
you know what i mean so
i i don't i don't like the look i i
that's how i feel about this i don't
like the look of it i think it reeks of
privilege it does
and it makes you know it makes women
feel bad man and women pay money too to
watch nfl games you know it's like you
know women are in households with men
who might be like you know i want to
support this and they're looking out
being like why would you support the
thing where the these 30 women
are not feeling they're not feeling like
they're heard i mean it's a thing you
know
and he did settle the cases but him
settling the cases also doesn't mean
that he's guilty i mean it's like you
can't get your reputation back it's done
for him
you google his name for the rest of his
life this is gonna come up so you're not
gonna ever be innocent so just get rid
of this why why try to fight this in
court it's gonna go on forever and ever
and ever uh you know these women feel
like hey i want some compensation for
what you did to me he's got enough money
give him money and then be done with it
that's the advice probably of his
lawyers and there's a few of them that
are not taking the settlement and maybe
they want more
or maybe they're like nah man i want
more or i want to take this all the way
and get to go to court and have the
court be like okay
six million dollars each or whatever
they're trying to get at this point
whatever they feel they need to do they
need to do but all i'm saying is this
man it's not a good look i'm not damning
deshaun watson this ain't even about him
anymore we already got his thing we know
his kink we got his thing and we know we
have to decide for ourselves if we
believe
it was you know malice if it was ill
intent if it was like you know he made a
huge mistake in his judgment about this
uh you know and
look and and by the way if if even if he
was being someone that was like being
like
really bad about it if he was being bad
about it you know what i mean
that he's really stupid okay because
let's say if you believe he's guilty of
like you know intimidation and really
forcing then it's like dude you're not
even covering your tracks well
he got instagram messages and all this
stuff so it's like it that's the whole
point like the whole thing is
embarrassing whether you believe he's
super guilty or whether you believe it's
like oh this is all a misunderstanding
wherever you fall in this it's still 66
different massage therapists 30 are
saying they were they felt something
inappropriate happen
that's an embarrassment to your business
if you're an nfl and i think the nfl is
saying
all right that
we believe that this is enough these six
games
and 250 000 fine
i think that if the arbitrator would
have came out because she also had the
ability to give also a fine i think this
should have been a huge fine i don't
know if it would have made it better i
don't know if it would have made people
feel good but i'm telling you i think
that to me i'll say it again i feel like
the nfl can still add to the suspension
but to me i feel like they should have
went to him and been like okay you
didn't play all last year but you still
made a a significant amount of your
money from your contract we're gonna
find you a million dollars a game from
last year and that's time served then
we're gonna take this 17 million dollars
we're gonna either divvy it up amongst
the victims and we're gonna start
supporting
causes
to help women in these situations to
show that you really care about this
it's either that
or you
shouldn't have allowed him to sign a
contract in the first place
like that's the thing too because you
allowing him to sign a contract and work
for your company is a it's a trigger to
women out there that like yeah we'll
we'll kind of like we'll do whatever we
need to do
we'll we'll give you some you know you
know six seven eight game appeasement
even a year maybe a year isn't even
enough for some people and then he's
still gonna be able to go so the optics
of this to me
did not look good okay
it didn't look good to me i that's how i
feel about it guys i feel that the um
the optics of this is just not good okay
and then i see on the poll on the chat
here what wha
i didn't i didn't spell it right i was
supposed to was six games but it said
what six games was it's supposed to be
was six games enough of a suspension
sorry for the typo
but you guys got it and right now it's
like 57 percent of you guys say no and
43 say yes
i would love to hear
from people who are voting yes in the
chat why you think 20 the six games is
enough
of a suspension knowing all the details
um why is that so if you want to say
that
in the chat i would love to you know
hear what you have to say but
anyway that's my feeling on it um
yeah and i see what some people are
saying it's like if he he's basically
admitting guilt
you know
i i get what you're saying i get what
you say but what i'm saying is this
what was he doing
like there's you know you know what i
mean like
it's like admitting guilt or like if
he's i know that's the tough part about
this like we don't live in a world where
a guy could come out and be like yeah i
love
getting jacked off by my massage
therapist i love it it's my thing and
i'm totally willing to like pay extra
and and i like to ask for it you know
like you know and it's like you just go
does that
there's a part of you that makes that
like that sounds reasonable
you know what i mean he's a millionaire
he comes into a place he's like yeah i
really want to massage but afterwards
can you do this
uh
you know
i got i got this amount of money i gave
you 500 extra you know and if she says
no i'm not really into that he should be
like cool no problem but i still want my
massage or walk the hell out of there i
don't know but we just don't live in a
society where that's
that sort of transaction thing it's
always it always comes down to this like
thing of power and you know i don't i
just don't think men we don't really
understand
how it is like have you guys ever been
out with someone a woman who's you know
they're smaller than you and stuff and
you think
like you think you're being whatever but
maybe you're flirting you're mate saying
whatever and then she's responding a
certain way and then later she comes out
and was like
you know i was really uncomfortable
and to you you're saying you're a nice
guy
but you were just taking your shot you
know what i mean and you didn't realize
that she don't know you she don't know
what you're capable of so she just felt
well i'm just gonna go with this because
i don't know what this dude's gonna do
that's fair it's fair on that person's
side and it's also fair of the guy to be
like hey that's not wasn't my intention
at all and you know i i wasn't trying to
make make you feel that way but you have
to understand the other side i mean it's
like i think both sides don't really
talk about it enough in that way it just
always comes to like well
you know men are terrible and uh you
know or the other side people like oh
women are lying or whatever i think that
there's like a fur
a further discussion case by case that
should happen but in this situation man
come on man
66 different massage therapists i mean
it just
like what do you think's going on you
know even if it just
i don't know
that's just
that's how i feel about it
um
you know i hear somebody saying today
society money plays from women accusing
rich guys is a way of life and sad thing
to majority okay i understand that that
is just like real
that's like a a thing but imagine you're
a woman now and that is the first
assumption that people make i think
that's dangerous man i think it's dan i
think believe all women is dangerous i
believe that's dangerous and i also
believe it's dangerous to just make the
assumption that because it's a woman in
a rich guy a powerful guy that
automatically she's just trying to get
money that's unfair i mean think about
how unfair that is to actual victims
first of all
there's two times people showed a true
personality what are those times when
they drunk and when they rich
not everybody that has money treats
people right
and
you know there are people that get money
power and influence and they start to
act up man they change they act
different they feel there's a sort of
entitlement that goes to money and power
and you don't understand how
intimidating that can feel just think
how you guys might act even when you go
to a restaurant if you go to a fancy
restaurant and sometimes people have an
attitude with the help they got an
attitude with the person bringing their
food and they feel like they're the king
of the world they start to talk down and
start to i mean there's a dynamic at
play here that it's not always what you
think but it should be case by case
that's why i say
you know you you got to be careful with
strangers
people you don't know
you know it's like i don't know this
person i don't know what they about i
don't know what they're going for and so
like it's partly a dumb tax people are
paying on both sides
if it's a woman who's enamored by some
rich guy who's like ooh you know and and
and then like they get in there and then
the guy's like a dick and then you're
kind of feeling like whoa this isn't
what i wanted and he's acting you know
and then the other guy the rich guy
who's just trying to be nice and
thinking like yo let's go let's go to my
place let's go to this and you don't
realize how intimidating you're acting
or how that person feels because you
don't know their history so now you got
this misunderstanding going on and then
it goes into the public eye on twitter
because [__] gotta put their
whole goddamn life on twitter now
we don't know what's going on now we're
judging them being like oh she's just a
gold digger or we're going like oh men
are terrible when it's case by case and
i think that we got to take a beat and
look back so i do think it's dangerous
to have that
immediate feeling of like oh it's just a
gold digger like don't do that guys
don't be that guy you know what i mean
let's find out once we find out then we
can be like well here it is because uh
you know people have their day
um
yeah so that's just how i feel about
that i'll keep this pulled up a little
bit longer and you know i'll keep
looking at the ch at the chat you know
you know put the highlight at me so i
can see it as i'm as i'm going through
this thing you know but uh yeah guys uh
that's
um how i feel about
that
um
but let's talk some more about doordash
door dash
doordash
uh
i love doordash
um
if you're ordering all your summer
essentials with doordash by you know use
the dash pass
it's a great way to get everything you
need and during the summer of dash pass
you can save money and access members
only offers
that help
you feel easy and breezy all season long
you know sometimes you need like some
stuff that you didn't get at the
supermarket and you want to get it you
can use doordash and it's pretty great
with with zero delivery fees exclusive
items and more than 25 000 members only
offers nationwide
dash pass by doordash has everything you
need to make your summer memorable
with your dash pass by door dash
membership you can save an average of
four to five dollars on every order you
place for delivery or pick up
that's pretty good
i've saved a bunch of money that means
an average dash pass pays for itself
when you order just twice a month
because there's a fee with members only
offers and items dropping every week
you'll have everything you need to make
the most of summer right at your
fingertips
i like that you can get donuts from
doordash rachel and i there's this one
shot we go to we always use door dash
that's great shine bright during door
dashes summers of dash pass and get 50
off your first order up to 15 value use
promo code griffin at checkout when you
spend 12 or more that's 50 off your
first order up to 15 value when you sign
up for doordash during summer of dash
pass using promo code griffin don't
forget that's code griffin for 50 off
your first order of 15 value dash pass
benefits only on eligible orders that
meet the minimum subtotal terms
apply
all right guys
we did it
paid the bills
okay
um and thank you guys for the super
chats and becoming a member and all that
it's great let's end the poll i mean
pretty much you know i think a majority
of you i don't see a lot of people
uh saying
um like you know there's like a lot of
sentiment like a manly sentiment here
people this one guy said ricky hernandez
women think men can read your mind if
you feel uncomfortable but don't speak
up don't assume the man has the mental
capacity to read your nonverbal cues
but deshaun watson is an idiot on this
one okay
i
disagree with you ricky
i understand your sentiment about what
you're saying right but what i'm trying
to explain to you is and dax shepard
said this best about men not
understanding the female perspective i
don't know your stature man i don't know
how tall you are i don't know how big
you are but i am six three two one okay
so
you know what i mean i'm a big dude all
right and if you are you know a chick
she's five eight
125 pounds or you know what i mean
whatever it is it's like i don't care
what verbal cues you're gonna make
if you've had a bad experience with a
man in the past you're not sure how this
guy's gonna react you're not sure if
some guy's gonna grab your arm and be
like you know you're gonna do this right
now you don't know so like you're airing
on the side of caution
and that's what i'm saying don't put
yourself in an uncomfortable situation
with a stranger
that's why it's like you know you meet
someone go out in public talk to him on
the phone first really find out about
this guy get some opinions about the
person i think that's where the mistake
lies
is when we we hang out with a stranger
in a private situation and we don't know
what's going on but you can't assume
that a woman is just gonna be like okay
with being like oh excuse me i'm really
feeling uncomfortable right now
uh you know what i mean like that's why
the the issue is really before you get
to that point but i don't blame anyone
in that situation who is feeling like
i'm feeling uncomfortable because of my
past personal experience man and so you
have to remember that just try to keep
that in mind when you're thinking about
this kind of stuff
uh
you know what i mean
you know so it's like and i get it
listen man there's like there's you know
often think about it like this
of the 66 women that desean watson got
massages from
there might be 20 of them who were down
for the down for it you know one of them
being like i'm cool with this i totally
get it and it was like whatever he paid
him extra and he they were like cool i'm
down with it i mean i've seen like have
you ever seen like i saw this thing this
article was like it was called stripper
diaries or stripper stories and it was
these strippers telling us like these
these crazy stories like i'll never
forget one one girl was like yeah i
turned 18 i started stripping and my
friend my father's friend paid me 20 000
to uh you know have a good night with
him and she was like no regrets i have
fun and now i got 20 000 in the bank you
know i mean you know what i mean like
empower yourself it's fine but what i'm
saying is there is a situation where
you're in a little room think of it like
this you're a little massage therapist
you're in a room with this
professional athlete okay
he's got his clothes off you see the
muscle you're in a room
you
you maybe you don't have the wherewithal
to be like yo this is making me
uncomfortable you know what i mean or
you just you know
you just you want to leave or you you
know you got a terrible boss who's like
you know hey make sure the clients you
know you're not trying to like you're
not trying to jeopardize the business
either you know there's so much to think
about it's all i'm saying
there's so much to think about so don't
just have this like immediate idea that
like all women are gold diggers and all
men are terrible okay
let's just take a beat go case by case
and think about it like that okay enough
of that let's end the poll
for the most part i think a majority of
you believe that
fifth that
uh six games wasn't enough okay
all right
um next up on the agenda let's go light
i saw a show and you guys know how i
love talking about tv shows that i that
i watched and so i saw this show where
is it here it is
i saw this show um
it was called reacher
on
on amazon prime
and it was like i believe it was only
eight episodes yeah
eight episode series i don't know if you
saw the movie jack reacher with uh
tom cruise
um i really liked it um i i really did
it's it stars this guy
uh what's his name
what's his name alan richardson richson
richards richson that's a weird spelling
but he's a giant of a man dude
you know what i mean this dude is a
giant of a man um
you know and it's like so it's about you
know jeff if you remember the jack
creature
uh let's see let's read their little
description jack reacher was arrested
for murder and now the police need his
help based on the books by lee child
so you know john reacher comes to town
he's an ex-military police
you know green beret special forces
badass he worked he was military police
and he you know he has a great service
record medal of honor all this stuff
he's traveling around and he's like you
know he's the kind of guy that you know
it's like the incredible hulk television
show where he doesn't like you know he
don't have money in his poc he got like
a hundred dollars in his pocket no
wallet no social media he just travels
by foot by bus and just collects his
money from western union on his pension
and he just goes about his business he
gets to a town there's a murder he's
accused of murder and then now
uh you come to find out he has to he
kind of gets involved and try has to
solve the case so
i'll say this i i did a um i did a
a review of terminal list which was
another eight episode sort of like mini
series
that i thought it was entertaining and
i'ma say the same thing about this one
the guy's a decent enough actor he's
great with the physical stuff you know
it's exactly what you expect is going to
happen you know what i mean he's a smart
aleck he beats people up he's and he's
trying to solve this case and there's a
bad guy there's good guys there's a love
interest and what i like about this
is that
when you do eight episodes of a story
that has a beginning middle and end you
can really dive into the story you
really get into like meeting who the
characters are and what they're doing is
that acting great no
okay i'm gonna be 100 with you
uh
you know what i mean i i it wasn't like
you know but i enjoy it if you have
amazon prime i i recommend this you need
something to watch and you want to watch
it over a few days and you need you know
you need something that's like just
mindless fun
sort of like guilty pleasure fun reaches
that show for you
it's great action
he's great i like this guy this guy alan
richardson he's he's actually a
serviceable enough actor in this role i
believed him you know because you know i
don't believe him as much as i believe
tom cruise but we're talking about tom
cruise right so this guy did a really
great serviceable job uh uh i think it
was
you know good job dude i do recommend it
and i'm giving it some woo-woos
[Music]
so
yeah
we go in the episode on that like i say
make sure you guys
check out the check out reacher it was
it was good man
um
you know it was good i didn't keep this
one up as much as i should have because
as i look at it it looks kind of like
you know you know i mean the shirtless
pick you know i mean
it's like
you know reacher you know what i mean
it's i think
i think it's the kind of show they have
a strong female lead in it it's like a
good heroine in it and it's like it's
good man heroin i didn't say that right
it doesn't sound right but yeah man so
that is
um
[Music]
that's that for uh reacher and like i
say i do
uh highly recommend it so as you know at
the end of the show
at the end of the show i hit you guys
with
um
here comes the rap keep the rap uh
what do you call it
recap the rap recap but thank you for
watching riffing with griffin y'all
and this is from fishy
i've had one of his beats before but
this is a beat from fishy y'all and we
want to thank him i want to thank
everybody for watching ripping with
griffin y'all make sure y'all subscribe
hit the subscribe button y'all
make sure you know i'm uh on twitch
every single day
eric griffin gaming
yeah i want to thank everybody that was
here
oh yeah
[Music]
there was another riff in the crypt
everybody was ripping
[Music]
and i'm rocking this stone
watson is a freak
he should've moved his [__] feet
he was in there trying to speed
[Music]
that's how we do it
[Applause]
[Music]
make sure you watch
eric griffin is the teacher
[Music]
and that's it